player unknowns forth monthly update is  live now on battlegrounds test servers  and it introduces a new first-person  only mode to solo and duo games we  decided to jump into a few solo matches  to get the initial feel for this new  mode and right from the get-go we found  the view to be considerably restrictive  in the first person and firefights felt  much more up close and personal so  whether you're checking out our gameplay  now or you had a chance to try the mode  for yourself do you think this  first-person mode will add more  intensity and difficulty to the game let  us know in the comments below and for  more coverage on games patch notes and  updates consider hitting the subscribe  button  [Laughter]